[Music]
it was Europe's second biggest Reservoir
but now looks more like a desert what
was a vast Lake for seven decades was
robbed of its water in just a few days
it's really sad and it's scary we just
want it to be like it used to be
Andrew is an engineer in charge of
pumping water out of the reservoir
sucked into these huge intakes can you
remember the moment that you heard the
dam had been blown up and what did you
think when you heard that is
I didn't believe that something like
that could happen I can't believe that a
human brain can even consider that kind
of barbaric act I just can't believe
that
in the pumping station just Birdsong
it's big Soviet era machine should be
pumping water at the rate of 4 million
liters an hour
not anymore
the water should be going into a vast
network of pipes and canals in the
months before Harvest
normally this canal is full of water at
a level way above my head it's
completely empty now and bone dry the
water is normally sucked into these big
pipes and taken out onto the fields over
a million Acres of Farmland on both
sides of the reservoir depend on these
canals for irrigation giving you an idea
of the scale of the disaster caused by
the dam being blown up
Ukraine may be famous for its rich black
soil but it's not much use without water
farmer Anton says his Harvest could be
cut by as much as two-thirds
if we had water and the irrigation work
we could Harvest 10 or 12 tons per
hectare but without it we'll be lucky to
get five it depends if it rains
but there's more to worry about here in
the distant Zappa region nuclear power
station the ukrainians say Russia has
now mined it and could blow up part of
it next
six miles from the plants on the
Ukrainian side of the reservoir the town
of maracanets
they've had no water in their Taps here
since the damn blue it's being trapped
in instead
it's very bad very bad I have a small
child and every day I need to carry at
least 12 of these bottles and they're
also deeply alarmed by what Vladimir
Putin plans to do now
of course I'm worried we're worried
about the nuclear power station we're
worried about just about everything
where should we go if something happened
at the plant water's okay we can cope
with that but if there's an explosion
over there what do we do
of course because there are a lot of
rumors the power plant is mined at any
point it could just blow we already have
no water in the river denipro and they
can easily just walk here
the reservoir is no longer a natural
defense against the enemy now it's been
reduced to Mud Flats the nuclear power
station menaces the town across its
rooftops and there's the question if
Russians could destroy a dam and a
reservoir what are they planning to do
here next Dominic wagorn Sky News
macronets